okay here we go
random subscriber
hey i think it works
so i'm playing sam okay
it passed the first test good luck to
sound
lucky 13 4 leaf clover also happy 13
months to nerd of many things
welcome back to the veena
hacky sack legend
oh yeah i posted a video
a few hours ago on instagram
of some pretty intense hacky sack
[Laughter]
should do more hacky sack contents
warm greetings from liverpool
oh welcome back to thing duster
wait a minute i feel like you said the
the same thing
last time
um because i i just edited a youtube
video
which i plan on posting like sometime
the next day or two
where the video starts with that exact
message from thing duster
i think it was during the classical
shield arena
but maybe not
ah i think it was a bit message
yeah we do have a 10 second cooldown for
the lee chess command
maybe it would make sense to have five
seconds
of course we can see
let's see what we need to do based on
how it works
welcome back to simply girth hey boo you
fresh as heck keep doing you
oh thank you
yeah trying to stay fresh here
it's the first game of the stream
it's probably the freshest i'll be all
stream
okay
i want to show no mercy here
let's start with this move
there's a really funny line
i feel like white's gonna ruin it though
but maybe not
oh my queen oh no
ah
i was expecting knight p3 or knight c2
greetings from
[Music]
oh
funny line achieved
good game sam
[Music]
yeah i was expecting uh h3 to be played
it's my go to greeting your kind is like
a steel trap which is not quite as good
as a rose and stalemate trap but close
or an oh no my queen trap
h3 would have ruined all my fun
but c3 man
that was too much fun here
loving this steady stream of content
eric
oh and oh no your queen